man muss sicher dass man auch gegen das
recht schweren traumatisierung nicht im
eigentlichen sinne zu heilen sind
sondern das sind seelische narben die
diese kinder dann später auch erwachsene
jedem land mit sich herumtragen und die
man wird nicht ganz genau vorhersagen zu
welchen symptomen oder schwierigkeiten
das im detail wird aber sind menschen
die besondere unterstützung brauchen
die ganz am ende vielleicht auch ein
einigermassen zufrieden smeaton werden
leben können aber wie er immer wieder
beeinträchtigt wird sie werden denn
kinder vom missbrauch ganz zu beginn
betreut was sind die ersten schritte
wenn sowas entdeckt wird zuallererst
muss man die kinder in sicherheit
bringen das heißt körperliche sicherheit
bringen und dann durch die beschwerde
wieder hoch als auch der report
beziehung dafür sorgen dass die
kundschaft und dass ich mich da fühlen
und dass sie dann in diesem raum
aufwachsen können
bei dem sie sicher sein können dass so
etwas nie wieder passiert das geht nur
durch digitale dieser pädagogische und
therapeutische bedeutung
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video unten vergiss nicht zu abonnieren